hello everyone and welcome back to the
1921 World Chess Championship match
between josé raúl capablanca and Emanuel
Lasker so far so far we've seen two
games both of them were drawn in Game
one kappa blanka tried d4 against Lasker
we had a nice Queens gambit declined but
the game like we said ended in a draw in
Game two
Lasker also opted for the Queens gambit
declined he also played d4 the game
ended in a draw but here a couple Blanca
decides to mix it up and he plays efore
so let's see how Lasker deals with this
approach so we have a game three Alaska
replies with E 5 we have 90 f3 Knight to
c6 and now Knight to c3
we have knife to f6 the four Knights
defense is on the board and Bishop to b5
now of course the the Spanish variation
with d6 Capablanca attacks in the center
with d4 with Bishop to d7 and now
castles last Burgos Bishop to e7
prepares the Castle kingside
with rook to e1 just nicely developing
captures on d4 captures on d4 and Alaska
now just castles Capablanca decides to
trade on c6 that's how you you played it
in those days with Bishop captures on c6
b captures on c6 so for the moment
giving back the bishop pair and now
Bishop to g5 but you have somewhat
ruined his pawn structure on the Queen
side you know it's a trade off as it
always is with h6 by Oscar Bishop to h4
and now rook to e8 and here a queen -
sorry Queen to d3 capablanca is now
ready to lift the rook to e3 bring
another rook over to e1 and continue the
game with Knight to the h7 well ask her
and here a couple Blanca mentions that
Bishop captures on e7 is a move usually
played here every chess master will play
it but he himself feels that Bishop to
g3 is the the correct way to go but okay
the engine even agrees with Capablanca
that you should not trade the bishops
here but he decided to trade it he has
more games in this water champagne
should match so if this doesn't work out
he can always try the other line that he
thought was a superior one to this this
line we have rook after Sonny 7 and now
rook to e3
c'mon guys now ready to bring the other
look into the game and so what do you do
here
Queen to b8 rook the BH seems like mmm
seems like a move you'd want to play you
want to develop your rook you don't want
your Queen blocking your rogue but
Lasker goes for this approach and
capablanca blocks it would be three even
though the b3 is not a defense against
Queen Catherine beat you you cannot
capture the pawn capablanca could have
continued rook 81 and you still cannot
capture because of this very old trick
just a ruby one attack the Queen Queen
a3 and now of course you all know this
trick mostly we will see it in the
Sicilian will when black goes Queen to
a5 but here it also works just Knight to
d5 and now your queen is under attack
it's also undefended but your rook is
under attack and the capture of the rook
comes with check so you have to react as
your queen is under attack captures but
now a nice station soak Knight captures
with check King f8 captures captures and
now you only have a pawn for being down
the exchange and not something and not
something you should do
so b3 not a defense against Queen
captures on b2 but in the future you
will have a nice support when you want
to push c4 with Queen to b6 now also
making room for the rook and now rook 81
by kappa blanka rook 88 lasker also
brings his rooks into the game and now
Knight to f3
if Capablanca wants now he has
everything prepared to push e5 with
Queen to a5 now you can see that the
Queen and both rooks are putting
pressure on this rook on a one but also
the knight can't really move as Queen
captures on a two would they just win
the pawn so here Queen to d2 first now
you could try and trade queen with
something like Knights to a four block
the attack towards the a to pawn and
then maybe trade Queens but Lasker goes
in Knight to g5 now such a move is not
possible because Knight captures on f3
comes with check and then you would just
lose the Queen so Capablanca trades here
with Knight captures H captures and now
h3 just preparing to meet
g4 with H captures on g4 and it seems
seems nice for black but it doesn't
really do anything you don't really have
enough time to bring your pieces
something like Queen h5 rookie six
page six and try try to create an attack
here wife can just go f3 you have to
move and then King f2 and even if now
you decide to waste a lot of time
bringing your pieces over to the King
side white can even decide to hide his
king over and on the Queen side so here
look to e5 by Lasker and now look back
to d1 now kappa blanka says okay my
rooks are done on the e-file we will now
transfer them on the D file Bishop to c8
you don't want your bishop here as it's
a tricky square for the bishop because
let's say the Queen moves you could go
something like Knight a four to c5 and
you will not be able to capture because
you lose the bishop on d7 also black
would maybe have to triple his pawns on
the C file so Lasker just tucks it back
we were it safer we have looked at d3
and now Queen back to b6 now would ideas
of well bringing the rook over to e6 f6
and then the Queen and the rook will
nicely be attacking the f2 pawn with
King to h2 not allowing this pin to
exist here so now capablanca can even
push f3 so such ideas will no longer be
possible for Lasker Lasker continues
with his plan rook to e6 and now rook
the g3 attacking the the g5 point twice
now and rook to f6 now with the threat
of rook captures an f2 so here kappa
blanka thought about f3 but he decided
not not to go for it g4 and doesn't work
here if you go g4 white will not capture
and allow your rook to have to nor will
white capture with the h1 and the lie we
look to rook to h6 but white will go
Knights to a4 and now you can no longer
keep hold of this diagonal you'll have
to just move the Queen and then it's
just a silly pawn sacrifice
so after this every move that Capablanca
thought about playing he he didn't like
Queen to c5 it's just a just a nice move
and he you probably won't have anything
better other than Knights to a 4 and
then 25 with the attempt of trading
Queens so a couple Monica tries to keep
everything intact with King back to g1
now it's kind of sad
defending the f2 pawn would with the
king but for for the moment it works we
have king to f8 Alaska brain starts
ringing his king into the game also we
don't wanna
on the G file now that the rook occupies
it and nice day for attacking the Queen
Queen to a5 offering the Queen trade and
here a couple of encore trades with
Queen captures rook captures and not
rook to c3 cover Wonka says that
probably c4 was better here because he
played rook to c3 he wanted last pair to
go Bishop to d7 and then Knight c5 is
just a very nice move since you will
either have to triple your pawns and
give up the bishop on d7 or you're just
gonna have to play something like King
e7 to defend the bishop and then e 5 is
coming and a cup of lunch I thought that
this was just a superior position for
white however after rook to c3 last
Verdun defended with Bishop to d7 he
played Bishop b7 and all night to see
follow of course is pointless but now
come to Uncle Justin tinged with f3 and
now he will have to waste a move moving
the rook and gaining this pawn to c4
with rook that ecigs by Lasker and now
rook C to D 3 bush up to a 6 now
attacking the rook on d3
rook to d4 and now you could play
something like f5 it does seem nice but
after panca sorry after he captures an
f5 rook captures an f5 c4 will just be
very strong for white this bishop now
really it looks silly over there
so what last girl wants to do is prevent
white from pushing c4 so he just waits
with f6 now and rook 8 to c1 by kappa
blanka here you can't push c4 you see
why you can't push c4 it's a very nice
idea but feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out why c4 here fails
for white for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are a
masterful endgame player and for those
we've just want to enjoy the show
it doesn't work because well there's the
threat of Bishop captures on c4 and then
you lose the night well basically just
win a pawn first you kick away the rook
rook cast the move and now just Bishop
captures on c4 wins a clean pawn if you
capture you lose the night and then
black is just much better so a couple
Monica wants to push c4 but he has to
prepare it so first rook c1 he wants the
c4 pawn to be protected from from the
back rank and now just c5 by Lasker with
rook to d2 and now Bishop to b5 so
still not allowing c4 because then
Bishop character Sunday four would be
just much better for Black Knight back
to c3 by capablanca Bishop to c6 now and
now a four so instead of having this
pawn structure last word was able to
prevent it and now cover Blanca has it
this pawn structure which is definitely
not a disappear earphone structure so
Alaska definitely achieved something
here and our rook to a6 now he wants to
transfer to rook over to b6 push c4 and
bust open the position on the Queen side
King to f2 couple Monica starts bringing
the King into the game rook to b6 and
here nice to d1 couple Blanca now tries
to trick Lasker into playing this c4
move which would be a disaster because
if c4 then nice to e3 just the winds
back at the pawn not back but just wins
the pawn as you will not be able to
capture here because now you're just in
a terrible position you cannot move this
bishop because this pawn will be under
attack
it will be very very hard to defend it
whatever you play White's plan is to
push just a 5 rook see to force black to
move the bishop and then snatch the c7
point and then just go all out
so if black tries to prevent it let's
say five you get Knight to f5
threatening Knight d4 and after the rope
moves rookie five you still go here the
bishop is under attack and you don't
really have a good way of defending it
you have to move it and then the c7
point falls and it's all over
of course rook to c5 is impossible
because night here it just checks the
King and picks up the rook so a couple
on complete it in hopes of lasker
playing the c4 move but of course
Lasker's and you know he's a pretty good
chess player himself King to f7 and now
Knight to III just a much better square
for the knight with rook back to be
eight and now rook the h1 cover Blanca
now has ideas of thinking sorry King g3
pushing age four and maybe opening the
position on the Kings side as without
the b-pawn Lasker doesn't really have a
good way of breaking through through on
the Queen side as the knight as long as
the night covers the c-4 square you will
never be able to push c4 so with rook it
back to be eight and now rook d2 d1 I
will rook the h8 you know preparing for
a couple bunkers push on the
the kingside but here Capablanca decides
that he no longer wants to play King g3
he just plays g4 which is an odd
decision I mean you do get a nice
outpost for your knight on f5 and you
have a nice outpost for your knight on
d5 but it is very unlikely you will ever
be pushing h4 now that another
disappoint is in g4
Bushra back to d7 by Lasker we have
Knights to d5 and now rook the b7 just
defending the c7 pawn with King to g3
maybe where ideas of pushing Age 4 but
now rook to h4 by Alaska he just doesn't
allow it and now he says you're not
gonna break through on the Queen side
you're not gonna break through on the
Kings side if you cannot break through
in the center then it's pretty much a
draw and here kappa blanka has to decide
what to do here now the real question is
can you push f4 here well you can but
you don't really gain anything by it
because after you push f4 and even if
Lasker captures will check and you win
the rook on h4 it's just terrible for
white because you're getting checkmated
the g5 check you have to go up the board
the pawn covers the g3 square and I just
wrote b8 and there there's no defense
against Lucas yet checkmate
you would have to lose a lot of material
here but in the end you would again be
checkmated so f4 not an option
Capablanca goes rook to d3 he prepares
c4 and he wants the rook to guard the b3
point while he pushes c4 finally Bishop
to e6 by Lasker and now c4 we've looked
back to h8 now now Lasker no longer
afraid of the h4 move and now look back
to see one now if you push this then a5
is coming and you don't really have a
good way of breaking through here you
don't gain anything by capturing if h5
you're not breaking through here it's if
anyone's better here it's definitely
black so after rook a trade we have
looked back to see one backup Blanca and
now kink the e8 now last course plan is
to maybe bring this King over to c6 and
then maybe if the knight moves maybe
even all the way to the b3 pawn Knight
back to III by Capablanca King to d7
nice the g2 now again maybe with ideas
of creating a breakthrough on the Kings
side and now rugby to be a preparing to
shift the rook over to the Kings side if
needed
roof to e
one by capablanca King to c6 and now
night back to III and here rook bt 8 by
Lasker rook to be one with ideas of now
breaking through and on the Queen side
but now rook to h7 preparing to go for
up to 8 and now an attack here so
Capablanca has to bring back the rook we
have work to do - and now rook back to
be a not allowing before we have looked
back to d3 and now rook beat the h8 once
again attacking these dis h3 pawn with
rook to h1 defending it and now just
kink the b6 now maybe good ideas of
reaching the b3 pawn we've grouped the
h2 capablanca now no longer with an
active plan he just has to wait and see
and Alaska goes back he goes back
because if he tries to read you the pond
then whatever a cuppa Blanca place you
will just play Knight see to check and
kink kicking back so he will not be able
to to do anything here so King to c6 by
Lasker and now rook to h1 we've route
back to b8 applying pressure to the b3
pawn rook h2 and I look back to f8 with
rook 2 H 1 by cup 1 cup King to d7 and
now rook back to h2 with Bishop to f7
Knights the f5 now and just rook F back
to h8 with Knight back to III King to e6
and now Knight to d5 going after the c7
pawn but last we just defended rook the
c8 and after Knight back to e3 here
Blanca and Lasker both agreed that there
is no way for for either sides to break
through here even though as of now it's
basically Lasker who's pushing for more
than a draw here in this position so
that's game 3 over the 1921 World Chess
Championship match between a josé raúl
capablanca
and Emanuel asked her a third game in a
row that ends in a draw so we'll just
have to you know continue with the match
and see what happens in India other
games once again I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Mark Lefkowitz
Donald till to deal with some you little
chenko Tim O'Connor and Lawrence Morris
for conversion to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the Capablanca
saga of course maybe we were going to
check out the the the feeder Grand Prix
that started in in in Latvia and you
know just checking up in your
suggestions as usual think oh I will see
soon have an excellent rest of your day